bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débat et de reportage comme tous les
soirs du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat vous le savez la promesse
est dans le titre de l'émission donner
du sens à l'actualité se mettre au
service du public vous proposez des clés
de compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici le sommaire de ce 21
septembre j - 3 avant les élections
sénatoriales 170 sièges seront
renouvelés la moitié de l'hémicycle les
LR alliés au centriste vont-ils garder
la majorité Renaissance le parti
présidentiel va-t-il souffrir les verres
peuvent-ils tirer profit de leur bons
résultats aux dernières élections
municipales et puis le rassemblement
national espère revenir dans la Haute
Assemblée quelles sont ses chansons
décortiques les enjeux de ce scrutin
dans une minute et puis c'était un
discours historique un roi d'Angleterre
pour la première fois dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat avec une pointe d'humour
british
je suis bien conscient que ma visite
précède la rentrée officielle des deux
chambres de votre Parlement et je ne
peux que vous présenter mes excuses
d'avoir
interrompu votre pause
Charles III oblige les parlementaires à
avancer leur rentrée mais surtout ils
lisent quelques messages politiques sur
l'Ukraine sur l'urgence climatique sur
l'amitié franco-britannique également
fera le bilan de ce séjour en France et
de sa première année de règne avec nos
experts dans 3/4 d'heure mais d'abord
donc notre dernier zoom sur ces
élections sénatoriales après l'Isère et
le Pas-de-Calais notre reportage au cœur
de la campagne parisienne avec Jérôme
Rabier
c'est assez rare pour être souligné
toute la majorité municipale d'Anne
Hidalgo par rassembler à Paris
socialiste écologiste et communiste
peuvent espérer passer de 7 à 8 sièges
sur les 12 places de sénateurs en jeu
mais pas question le crier trop fort le
rassemblement n'a pas qu'un objectif
arithmétique il a aussi un objectif
politique Yann Bross a pour le PCF ou
encore Yannick Jadot pour les
écologistes feront à coup sûr leur
entrée au Palais du Luxembourg et eulv
pourrait même envoyer trois élus au
Sénat si le huitième siècle est conquis
mais c'est bien un combat commun qui est
porté c'est gagnant-gagnant le
rassemblement dans d'autres départements
les Verts vont soutenir des listes
conduites par des socialistes qui grâce
à cela seront élus donc l'objectif
c'était vraiment de faire progresser la
gauche au Sénat l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle écologiste passerait
ainsi du Parlement européen au Sénat
pour y prolonger ses combats j'ai
travaillé 14 ans sur les lois
européennes notamment en matière
d'environnement je sais combien et vous
savez combien la France est en retard
moi je veux contribuer dans le cadre
législatif à faire en sorte que les lois
françaises soient au moins à la hauteur
des lois européennes si la gauche par
confiance c'est qu'en face la droite
parisienne perpétue la tradition de la
division
de Catherine Dumas sénatrice sortante et
tête de liste officielle des
républicains qui a bien du mal à
l'expliquer aux grands électeurs
personnelles et oui elle est accompagnée
en deuxième position du ténor du barreau
et maire du 16e arrondissement Francis
spinner un choix qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité chez les élus et les grands
électeurs mais pour elle il n'y a pas
débat elle dirige la seule liste dignes
de semis en fait il y a
des
concurrents comme vous dites franchement
je me pose des questions je suis la
seule à avoir des élus sur sa liste
Elvis trois sièges pour sa liste mais
elle est fortement concurrencée
notamment par Agnès Evren euro député
président de la Fédération LR parisienne
qui n'a pas apprécié que le 15e
arrondissement dont elle est l'élue soit
mis de côté notre liste de
rassemblements et d'ouverture soutenu
d'ailleurs par le maire du 15e Philippe
Goujon et également Hervé Morin qui est
le président du parti centriste
permettra donc au 15e arrondissement le
plus peuplé de Paris d'être représenté
au Sénat elle est normalement assurée
d'obtenir assez de voies pour être élu
16 conseillers de Paris de droite ayant
soutenu sa candidature et malgré les
pressions elle est allée au bout de sa
démarche
alors aujourd'hui c'est un moment clé de
la campagne sénatoriale puisqu'il s'agit
de faire valider donc par la préfecture
les documents de campagne alors là vous
voyez c'est la profession de foi et puis
le bulletin de vote un troisième
bulletin de votre sera la disposition
des grands électeurs de droite Pierre
Charron élu depuis 2011 mais exclu de la
liste officielle ayant décidé de
repartir au combat ce jour-là il a
rendez-vous avec sa deuxième de liste
une novice en politique bonjour Pauline
très bien voici Pauline déroulette s'est
fait connaître pour son combat pour la
sécurité routière elle qui a perdu une
jambe renversée par une personne âgée
qui n'avait plus la capacité de conduire
à ses côtés Pierre Charon mène une
campagne médiatique et ira vu sur les
choix de sa famille politique on m'a
fait une
parlons français une petite saloperie je
veux pas l'accepter je savais pas
accepté à l'époque de Nicolas Sarkozy
j'ai pas l'accepter de Madame un tel ou
monsieur Retailleau un tarif il y a un
tarif c'est oui le paieront 24 ce
Sarkozy Story qui revendique aussi
quelques soutiens dans la majorité
présidentielle espérant emmener avec lui
sa colistier au Sénat ça a été pour moi
la pépite que je cherchais pour booster
cette liste et attaquer le deuxième
siège ce que nous faisons ardemment tous
les deux si Pierre Charron joue
l'ambivalence vis-à-vis de la majorité
présidentielle il n'y a officiellement
qu'un seul candidat du camp macroniste
Julien barjetton espère sauver le seul
siège parisien du mouvement présidentiel
il est légitimes qu'à Paris sur 12
sénateurs il y ait un sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle au regard de ce
que représente ce mouvement politique
dans la capitale et donc je me bats sur
cette liste il a pris soin de réunir des
élus du parti d'Édouard Philippe horizon
et du MoDem de François Bayrou mais il
aura besoin d'aller chercher des voies
au-delà de sa seule famille politique je
pense que c'est important de s'adresser
aux 2881 grands électeurs pour leur dire
à chacun aussi parler à d'autres que
vous connaissez nous on dit personne
n'est propriétaire des voix ça c'est je
veux dire c'est 2180 hectares il vote
dans l'isoloir
2880 grands électeurs parisiens qui par
leur votes désignerons donc 12 élus la
capitale étant la circonscription
électorale avec le plus de représentants
au Palais du Luxembourg
on analyse les enjeux de ce scrutin pas
comme les autres avec Sophie Coignières
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste au Point auteur de ce livre
la tyrannie de la médiocrité publiée aux
éditions de l'Observatoire Bruno
cotreize bonsoir politologue chercheur
au CNRS et aussi Charline bonsoir
constitutionnalisme bienvenue à vous
aussi Tam traduis bonsoir tams politique
Tim c'est le couteau suisse de la
rédaction de Public Sénat LC elle sait
tout faire au prolonge ce zoom sur Paris
peut-être il faut le faire c'est la
règle déjà et on respecte les règles en
redonnant la liste complète des
candidats je vais redonner leur nom
Catherine Dumas pour LR Agnès Evren
lrdiscidante lobna stadi vers écologiste
Pierre Charron et rdcante Julien
barjoton majorité présidentielle Marion
Beauvallet elle est fille Rémy fero Lyon
de la gauche François bécho divers
écologistes ça c'est fait un petit tour
de table sur Paris parce qu'après il y a
beaucoup d'autres enjeux nationaux à
décrypter Sophie cognat
il y a des moments on peut pas ne pas
sourire en voyant le sujet notamment ce
bal des dissident à droite c'est ça que
avec avec deux personnages quand même
qui chacun dans son genre
imprime Pierre Charron
on l'a vu à l'oeuvre même avec le peu de
temps de parole qu'il avait dans votre
sujet comme tous les autres il arrive
quand même à nous faire rire il faut
bien le dire ou elles arracher à tout le
moins un souvenir
et il parle vrai c'est vrai qu'on lui a
fait une saloperie donc voilà et puis
Agnès est reine qui je trouve à
comment dirais à une espèce de présence
de charisme qu'a fait une me dit-on
les grands électeurs trouvent qu'elle a
fait une vraie campagne et donc oui il y
a du suspense à droite
là comment vous dire bon c'est tout ce
que c'est pas ça qui va changer la face
du Sénat donc
un micro enfin c'est une tempête pas
dans un verre d'eau mais dans un à
l'intérieur du périphérique on va dire
néanmoins c'est quand même une image de
la droite
peu problématique pour rester aimable
évidemment unchaine bézina c'est on peut
revenir sur le mode de scrutin alors il
est un peu compliqué donc on va pas se
lancer dans une explication trop longue
mais à Paris comment ça se passait quoi
une campagne électorale parisienne mais
alors précisément c'est vrai que c'est
pas quelque chose de très connu l'idée
de faire campagne pour les élections
sénatoriales mais au fond c'est
totalement une réalité sur le terrain
parce qu'on a deux modes de scrutin pour
laisser la toriales c'est aussi tout
toute l'originalité de ce Sénat c'est
que en dessous d'un certain nombre de
sièges et bien on va être au scrutin
majoritaire c'est-à-dire on va choisir
un nom mais au-dessus d'un certain
nombre de sièges et bien au contraire on
est à la proportionnelle c'est-à-dire
qu'on choisit des lits alors on est
censé avoir un petit peu moins
d'incarnation et pourtant on le voit
bien même à Paris où on a Adou siège
c'est à dire la voilà la circonscription
a mieux représentée et bien il y a quand
même des enjeux de personnalité donc
campagne pour les sénatoriales ça
signifie en fait imprimer localement et
on voit bien que justement les LR ont
cette longueur d'avance par rapport à
d'autres parties même si il y a
plusieurs nuances et ça ça sera
intéressant à suivre par rapport aussi
aux nuances qui a l'Assemblée nationale
on a l'impression qu'il y a plutôt aussi
sous cette partie au sein de LR des fois
et ça ça peut être cette leçon tirer
qu'est-ce que vous retenez vous de la
campagne parisienne peut-être Yannick
Jadot qui est un peu le la personnalité
que tout le monde a tant au Sénat on
verra s'il a été élu il a de bonnes
chances de l'être bah oui c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est au-delà de ce qui
se passe à droite on a vu que c'est
effectivement les Petits meurtres entre
amis qui se connaissent depuis tellement
longtemps pour le temps mais
effectivement il y a aussi le dessous
des cartes de ces élections sénatoriales
leurs dimensions un peu nationale et
c'est vrai que il y a des rapports de
force à l'intérieur de la gauche qui
sont très intéressants observés
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a pas eu d'accord
entre la France insoumise et les autres
formations de la gauche pour ces
sénatoriales et que tout ça à un moment
donné et ben ça va peser dans la balance
tout ce qui va se peser à gauche ce qui
va se passer à gauche et puis avec
l'arrivée effectivement de Yannick Jadot
voilà il Yannick Jadot un des grands
brûlés de l'élection présidentielle qui
vient au Sénat alors pour porter d'après
lui un message qui est l'importance du
Sénat pour la dimension de l'écologie du
concret des territoires et donc ça ça va
être quand même important d'avoir une
personnalité très identifiée par le
public en matière de combat écologique
au Sénat j'espère que ces nouvelles
arrivées vont permettre de beaux débats
sur ces sur ces questions mais c'est
vrai que ça va être une des un peu une
des stars de ces élections sénatoriales
un mot de la liste Renaissance Tam
Julien barjoton il peut espérer garder
son ciel il est sortant lorsqu'elle
particulier dans les élections à Paris
c'est qu'il faut le vote de 13
conseillers de Paris lui il peut compter
sur 11 donc mathématiquement c'est pas
évident c'est pour ça qu'on le voit dans
le sujet et dit il faut aller à la pêche
aux grands électeurs c'est à dire les
élus régionaux les parlementaires etc et
comptez sur les indécis et donc bah il
est pas très très bien même ici il a
réussi quand même à faire l'union avec
le Modem avec horizon ce qui n'était pas
du tout gagné d'avance on disait au
départ qu'il avait été lâché un peu par
l'Elysée au profit de Pierre Charon mais
il semblerait que maintenant finalement
il est plutôt un peu plus la plus
présidentielle sa situation elle est un
peu à l'image du groupe qui n'est pas
évidente avec un manque d'ancrage local
de renaissance et puis un popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron dans les territoires
un peu de pédagogie évidemment dans
notre débat ce sont donc on l'a compris
les grands électeurs qui élisent les
sénateurs 95% de conseillers municipaux
5% de conseiller départementaux
régionaux et de parlementaires est-ce
que ça veut dire uncharen beezina que
l'élection est écrite d'avance j'espère
bien que vous allez me répondre non et
c'est tout à fait ce que je vais vous
répondre Thomas parce que c'est un peu
d'ailleurs le prisme déformant du mode
de scrutin ou suffrage universel
indirect on se dit c'est quelque chose
de déjà voté si bien qu'en fait on
appelait pendant longtemps quand on
présente un peu ce mode de scrutin les
municipales le premier tour des
élections mais en réalité et l'un
d'ailleurs des élus la rappeler il y a
le secret de l'isoloir donc il y a
évidemment on l'a vu par exemple pour
les grands électeurs aux États-Unis il y
a des possibilités que les choix
évoluent au sein d'une même élection
donc rien n'est jamais allé les grands
électeurs ne votent pas non forcément
pour leur famille exactement non pas de
consignes de vote et alors qui plus est
quand les familles politiques sont à ce
point-là fracturées et bien ça laisse
toujours un suspense donc il y a ça et
puis en plus les sénatoriales elles sont
jamais acquises d'avance parce que au
fond toutes les questions d'alliance de
groupe on voit bien que on a plus du
tout une vie politique structurée autour
d'une bipolarité droite-gauche et le
Sénat continue un petit peu à incarner
quand même cette échiquier et
aujourd'hui a priori au moins sur cette
première tranche de sénateur élu et bien
on va avoir un sénat qui va mieux
représenter ses couleurs Sophie
Coignières vous dites que c'est des
élections elles sont un peu étranges
pourquoi vous dites ça
non non c'est des élections qui sont
comment vous dire pas forcément très
transparente dans l'esprit des gens
c'est pas très clair parce que d'abord
comme vous le savez il y a deux modes de
scrutin différents selon qu'on a moins
de enfin deux ou un sénateurs dans un
département voilà donc déjà ça c'est
quand même une quelque chose qui est un
peu surprenant c'est le quand on regarde
la composition du Sénat aujourd'hui il
manque quelques grandes familles
politiques si on se réfère à la
présidentielle c'est en ça que c'est un
peu oui alors ça c'est l'autre étrangeté
c'est à dire enfin jamais
avant l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'Élysée on aurait pu imaginer que la
chambre haute soit essentiellement
dominée par des formations dont le
représentant n'était ni numéro un ni
numéro 2 ni numéro 3 à la dernière
présidentielle si vous continuez
si vous prenez
les macronistes sont quand même je crois
24 en rabattant super large et c'est pas
sûr enfin on peut pas faire madame Yama
donc on a alors on peut se dire c'est
extrêmement bizarre et puis on peut se
dire aussi après tout c'est très bien
parce que là dans une démocratie je
trouve moi je suis plutôt je suis plutôt
comment vous dire allons-y enthousiaste
sur sur cette espèce de pluralisme du
coup avec une chambre haute qui
représente effectivement l'émanation des
élus locaux des territoires et bah les
élus locaux et les territoires ils sont
surtout ils se recrutent surtout à LR et
dans la gauche non mélenchoniste
ce qui a de nouveau je trouve quand même
dans cette élection c'est que le Sénat a
pris une elles sont un enjeu plus
important qu'avant parce que le Sénat
est devenu si j'ose dire plus important
qu'avant dans la politique à cause de la
majorité relative on va y revenir on l'a
dit beaucoup de fois mais aussi je crois
parce qu'il y a une aura du Sénat qui
est venue du fait que les commissions
d'enquête parlementaire par exemple on a
énormément servi à médiatiser le Sénat
elle lui donner une importance donc tout
à coup y compris chez les élus locaux et
je rebondis sur sur ce que disait malade
et bien y compris chez les élus locaux
avant il y avait une espèce
d'autobatisme c'est à dire en gros
j'appartiens à l'écurie x je voterai
pour le candidat X et basta et je pense
que là c'est un tout petit peu plus
ouvert à cause de ça
les surprises peuvent-elles aussi venir
des grandes villes parce qu'on dit
souvent ça des élus on va dire dans les
régions les plus rurales ou l'étiquette
politique s'efface dans un scrutin mais
est-ce que peut y avoir aussi des
surprises dans les grandes villes Paris
et les autres
sans doute mais moins on voit on voit
effectivement que l'idée qu'il n'y a pas
parfaite correspondance entre les
affiliations partisanes de ces grands
électeurs et leur comportement de vote
le jour des élections ça participement
d'une respiration démocratique on
pourrait dire le jeu partisan respire un
tout petit peu plus
l'équation personnelle les logiques de
territoire sur lesquels on des
personnalités politiques ont peut-être
agi dans des bords politiques différents
mais au service d'un même territoire et
de ce point-là c'est une bonne
respiration démocratique et je partage
pas mal ce que vous venez de dire alors
peut-être à une à une nuance près parce
que le fait que des formations
politiques qui sont très présentes dans
notre vie politique qui sont des piliers
de la vie politique Emmanuel Macron a
gagné deux fois la présidentielle Marine
Le Pen qualifiait deux fois mon deuxième
tour de la présidentielle Jean-Luc
Mélenchon une fois troisième une fois
quasi troisième de la présidentielle le
fait qu'ils aient si peu de sénateurs à
la fois je vois bien la logique qui est
de dire
pas mal depuis des années je vois bien
la logique de dire il y a une
institution dans notre système
institutionnel qui échappe un peu à
l'étau de la présidentielle de se
trouver là c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant d'avoir ça mais peut-être à
ce point poussé l'absence de
représentant de ces courants politiques
et un peu on va dire un peu de décalage
avec l'opinion publique le fait que ces
familles là soient pas ou peu
représentés oui à la fois je pense qu'on
peut assez facilement assumer l'idée que
le Sénat ne représente pas la même vie
politique que l'Assemblée nationale les
présidentielles le gouvernement en place
et moi je crois que c'est très sain pour
une chambre haute justement alors il y a
cette dichotomie en droit
constitutionnelle entre les chambres
hautes représentent les territoires et
celles qui représente plutôt les castes
sociales on a longtemps dit du Sénat qui
représente un petit peu les deux
justement aujourd'hui on l'a dit il y a
un changement d'image du Sénat mais
c'est cette idée aussi et vous l'avez
dit les territoires locaux n'ont pas du
tout la même
le même fonctionnement eu égard au parti
politique que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale donc le
Sénat représente aussi la vie politique
dans nos territoires et donc ne va pas
voter les lois de la même façon va
porter un regard très différent et je
crois que c'est vraiment très important
on va rappeler quelques fondamentaux le
travail d'essayer de maîtriser des
sénateurs c'est de faire la loi écouter
tiens jean-Pierre Sueur sénateur
socialiste du Loiret il ne se représente
pas il va quitter le Sénat après 22 ans
de mandat c'était il était invité de la
matinale de Public Sénat et il répond la
question quels conseils donnez-vous au
sénateur qui vont arriver
bien sûr au sénateurs qui vont arriver
qui vont vous succéder vous qui
connaissez par cœur cette maison
qu'est-ce que vous auriez envie de leur
dire
d'être des sénateurs à temps plein c'est
à dire de prendre le temps d'aller sur
le terrain bien sûr trois jours par
semaine mais de passer des jours et des
nuits à faire des amendements à étudier
les textes à faire des propositions de
loi et il dit parce que quand vous
faites une loi elle va s'appliquer
pendant très longtemps de Dunkerque à
Marseille de Brest à Strasbourg donc il
faut beaucoup réfléchir les bonnes lois
c'est comme le bon vin il faut du temps
Bruno cotresse
magnifique le sénateur Sud effectivement
des des
lois c'est du travail mais c'est du
travail c'est l'essence même du
Parlement c'est l'essence même du
Parlement la fabrication de la loi c'est
le rôle fondamental du Parlement qu'il
s'agisse de sa chambre haute ou basse
c'est le même objectif faire la loi et
le sénateur a bien raison de rappeler
que quand une loi est adoptée elle peut
avoir des conséquences sur les vies des
individus pendant des décennies même
vraiment donc c'est très important la
fabrication de la loi c'est le rôle du
Parlement et c'est vrai que c'est bon de
le rappeler que ces élections aussi un
moment de pédagogie pour rappeler à tout
le monde comment fabriquer la loi voilà
parce que c'est aussi une réponse au
fait que certains Français vont vous
dire que le Sénat n'a pas le dernier mot
et donc se pose tout le temps la
question de savoir à ce moment-là à quoi
il sert tout ne connaît pas le
fonctionnement de la navette
parlementaire le fait qu'on puisse
amender à tour de rôle le fait que il y
ait beaucoup d'accord en commission
mixte paritaire et que souvent la loi
s'écrivent à deux et puis Jean-Pierre
sénateur dans ces réunions les
commissions mixte paritaires et puis
Jean-Pierre soeur moi ce que j'entends
aussi c'est que c'était un fervent
défenseur du non-cumul des mandats et
des sénateurs à temps plein et donc là
dedans il y a aussi son testament il
l'assume cette position cette réforme de
François Hollande là où on sait qu'il y
a un certain nombre de sénateurs à
droite comme à gauche qui plus que ça a
pas été une bonne chose pour le Sénat
parce que ça a retiré certaines figures
de grand-mère qui avait de grands mères
une portée nationale voilà donc il y a
encore ce débat aujourd'hui sur
l'ancrage territorial très intéressantes
il le dit avec son ton patelin etc mais
en fait une énorme provocation enfin il
y a plein de il y a plein de ces futurs
ex collègues si j'ose dire qui qui vont
grimper au mur en entendant ça le nom
cumuler mandat parenthèse là-dessus
votre avis je crois que ça fait même
partie du programme politique d'Edouard
Philippe si je ne m'abuse qui n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat mais qui
lance quand même des propositions
institutionnelles qui ressemble de plus
en plus et c'est vrai que pour le Sénat
ça l'a frappé quand même à mon avis de
manière assez différente que l'Assemblée
nationale parce que le sénateur maire ou
le sénateur président de conseil était
vraiment très ancré depuis la Troisième
République Gambetta qualifié le sénateur
le Sénat du Grand Conseil des communes
de France donc il y a quand même cette
idée aussi de représenter les
territoires qui est dans l'article 24 de
nos constitution je voulais aussi dire
un mot sur le fait que le Sénat ne fait
pas que fabriquer la loi mais contre
l'action du gouvernement également
article 24 les trois missions du
Parlement et ça c'est vraiment illustré
là-dessus donc je pense que il l'aura
encore l'occasion de le faire évidemment
le Sénat donc renouvelé de moitié
dimanche presque 1 170 sièges sur 348 on
va détailler tout de suite les enjeux
politiques du scrutin grâce à Alexandre
Poussard qui doit être là Alexandre vous
pouvez nous rejoindre bonsoir allez on
va faire ça politique on commence par la
majorité sénatoriale des enjeux pour LR
et leurs alliés sans tristes il ne
devrait pas y avoir de séisme électoral
pour la majorité de droite et du centre
du Sénat a d'abord pour le groupe les
républicains le premier groupe du Sénat
avec 145 sénateurs dont 65 qui sont
renouvelables dimanche et il devrait
faire de bons résultats et bien car on
le rappelle les sénateurs sont élus par
un collège de grands électeurs composés
à 95% de conseillers municipaux et aux
dernières municipales de 2020 et bien la
droite avait gagné de nombreuses
communes notamment des petites et
moyennes communes et puis pour le groupe
centriste en bleu ciel le deuxième
groupe de la majorité sénatoriale et
bien la moitié de ces 57 sénateurs remet
son mandat en jeu dimanche dessinateurs
centrist dont certains soutiennent aussi
la politique d'Emmanuel Macron et il
faudra voir si cela va plaire aux grands
électeurs alors justement la majorité
présidentielle peut-elle gagner des
sièges au Sénat alors ça va être plutôt
compliqué pour le groupe renaissance du
Sénat le groupe RDPI qu'on voit en jaune
sur cette infographie il renouvelle 12
de ses 24 sénateurs et il pourrait
perdre quelques sièges en revanche le
groupe les indépendants en gris qui fait
partie de la majorité sénatoriale mais
qui est bien est composé de sénateurs du
parti horizon le parti Édouard Philippe
et il pourrait grossir ce groupe après
le scrutin de dimanche soir car la
formation politique d'Édouard Philippe
elle est plutôt bien implantée parmi les
élus locaux alors que peut-on dire de la
gauche maintenant Nupe pas Nupe accord
pas accord dit nous tout alors il y a un
accord entre des formations de gauche au
sénatoriale mais pas sur le modèle de la
nuque d'abord parce que la France
insoumise n'a pas beaucoup
d'implantations locales et ne devrait
pas gagner de siège de sénateurs en fait
il y a un accord mais entre les
socialistes les écologistes et les
communistes dans 15 départements qui
sont renouvelables cette année un accord
pour essayer d'assurer les différents
sièges de sénateur de sénateurs de ces
trois groupes politiques le premier
groupe de gauche au Sénat et bien c'est
le groupe socialiste avec 64 sénateurs
en rose 33 sont renouvelables et il
pourrait grappiller quelques sièges tout
comme le groupe écologiste en verre qui
espère des sièges supplémentaires
notamment à Paris avec on l'a vu la
candidature de Yannick Jadot en revanche
ça va être compliqué pour le groupe
communiste bouton rouge qui est un petit
peu en danger hein sur ces 15 sénateurs
11 sont renouvelables dimanche et on le
rappelle il faut au moins 10 sénateurs
pour former un groupe politique au Sénat
le rassemblement national pour terminer
ce qu'un groupe RN au Sénat est
envisageable alors c'est peu
probablement poser des questions de
probable Thomas on le rappelle le
rassemblement national il n'a pas de
sénateur aujourd'hui et il vise quand
même quelques sièges dans des
territoires qui sont très ciblés on le
voit sur cette carte des candidats RN
ont des chances d'être élus dans les
départements du nord du Pas-de-Calais et
de la Moselle alors c'est maigre
perspectives pour le parti de Marine Le
Pen et bien elle s'explique là encore
par des mauvais résultats du RN au
dernière municipales en 2020 evidemment
merci beaucoup Alexandre pousseur Sophie
Coignières on a vu là sur le l'hémicycle
les les toutes les nuances de bleu on
aurait pu en rajouter beaucoup c'est ça
qui est très intéressant quand on
analyse la majorité sénatoriale
on peut dire effectivement que
on n'a pas eu l'occasion d'éprouver
comment dirais-je cette palette de
couleur
à l'occasion de la réforme des retraites
mais on aura l'occasion de le faire
par exemple avec la loi immigration la
loi immigration va être me semble-t-il
une comment dirais-je une sorte de test
grandeur nature in vivo de la cohésion
ou pas de tout ce bleu ça c'est
intéressant
du scrutin on sera ensemble dimanche pas
seulement Alexandre tout ça pendant
l'antenne à 12h30 on sera ensemble à
partir de 17h30 jusqu'à 22h30 donc vous
allez le résultat évidemment minute par
minute des envoie spéciaux enfin tout un
bout dispositif les leçons qu'on va
tirer ce dimanche soir un challenge ça
sera beaucoup là-dessus en fonction de
la personnalité de tel ou tel sénateur
ou sénatrice centriste ou LR ou est-ce
qu'il se situer est-ce qu'il va plutôt
être pro majorité présidentielle plutôt
à la droite de la droite chez LR il y a
toutes ces nuances qu'on va pouvoir
décoder dimanche soir alors dimanche
je pense qu'on aura des informations
d'ordre d'étiquette politique mais c'est
vrai que tout va aussi se jouer au sein
de l'hémicycle et dans la manière d'un
carnet en fait une question fondamentale
pour l'identité du Sénat c'est de savoir
si elle va se situer comme une chambre
de la majorité ou plutôt une forme de
chambre du contre-pouvoir on avait
remarqué
depuis un an et demi on est d'accord que
même depuis le premier mandat d'Emmanuel
Macron le
sénates dans ce rôle avec les
commissions d'enquête de finalement de
chambre de contre-pied un petit peu
c'est pas nécessairement de l'opposition
mais c'est en tout cas une manière avec
ce contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
de montrer que le Sénat est utile à la
démocratie d'investigation alors ça
évidemment le groupe LR va nous aider à
savoir un petit peu si on est plutôt sur
un groupe LR la majorité ou opposition
c'est pas anodin de savoir d'ailleurs
que le groupe LR dès le départ à
l'Assemblée nationale lui c'est affilié
dans l'opposition alors qu'au Sénat
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup moins
violemment assumé de la part de Gérard
Larcher d'ailleurs même si il y a une
identité du groupe LRC qui n'est pas la
même que celle au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale donc au fond on se rend compte
que il y a non seulement des nuances
entre les deux chambres des nuances au
sein des groupes au sein des deux
chambres mais je crois qu'il y aura
vraiment aussi une manière d'incarner la
gouvernance qui va être intéressante à
vérifier
c'est un groupe pivot aujourd'hui au
Sénat il devrait le rester on peut
l'imaginer sans aucun doute alors là
c'est vraiment extrêmement intéressant
c'est une couche supplémentaire de
difficulté puisque la carte de ce groupe
il y a des gens par exemple qui sont
modem officiellement dans la majorité
présidentielle donc ça souligne encore
une fois cette question majorité
présidentielle majorité au Sénat est-ce
que ça correspond est-ce que ça
correspond pas et puis en toile de fond
on voyait tout à l'heure sur
l'infographie entre le jaune et le gris
aussi il y a beaucoup d'enjeux parce
qu'évidemment en qui font tout le monde
pense déjà à la présidentielle est-ce
que ça permet une affirmation monter en
puissance du côté des droits Philippe et
de son mouvement horizon au détriment
peut-être effectivement de du groupe
majorité présidentielle mais
effectivement au centre droit on voit
que ces élections sénatoriales vont nous
en dire aussi beaucoup des
positionnements des uns et des autres
une majorité
le camaïeu jusqu'au gris c'est à dire
que il y a d'un côté ce que je vous
dites qui est évidemment enfin
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le gris
et le gris est pas très loin du bleu
vous voyez ce que je veux dire et donc
là aussi enfin d'ailleurs Édouard
Philippe sont caché à peine de continuer
à vouloir faire travailler la poutre
comme il dit depuis longtemps
qu'est-ce qui va se passer aussi entre
horizon en tant que en tant que groupe
charnière entre la majorité et la droite
c'est-à-dire que là effectivement il y a
un éventuel travail de fracturation
amicale qui peut être effectuée donc
tout ça
je suis mille fois d'accord avec Bruno
cotress pour dire que il va falloir
surveiller de très près enfin moi c'est
ce que je vais faire le goût horizon je
pense que c'est vraiment des choses sur
lesquelles on devra zoomer en permanence
d'abord combien seront-ils puis ensuite
comment vont-ils se comporter la
majorité présidentielle le groupe alors
Renaissance crdpi mais bon on va on va
simplifier
dirigé par François Patriat Satan quand
même à une soirée un peu difficile
écoute le c'était lui aussi un invité de
la matinée
c'est difficile d'abord en tant que
président de groupe vous imaginez bien
que je vais vous dire aujourd'hui je
vais vous dire c'est difficile parce que
sur les 12 sénateurs sortants 4 ne se
représentent pas dans les secteurs ou
c'est déjà pas facile que pour les
autres la campagne aujourd'hui vous
allez les copains vous savez les
élections intermédiaires c'est
l'occasion pour les électeurs style des
élus de se venger que sur le
gouvernement partout c'est difficile
d'avoir les étiquettes de la majorité
présidentielle
3 ans quand j'ai fait campagne j'ai fait
une campagne difficile
Bruno cotress c'est il faut quand même
rappeler faire peut-être un peu
d'histoire politique c'est long
d'installer parce que on peut dire là
aussi échec d'Emmanuel Macron qui a pas
réussi son ancrage local alors que ça
fait 6 ans qu'il est au pouvoir sauf que
ça prend du temps il y a d'autres
exemples dans notre histoire de d'en
créer un nouveau parti politique oui
c'est également c'est à la fois très
long et d'autant plus difficile pour des
mouvements politiques du type de celui
qui Emmanuel Macron a créé ce qu'on
appelle un peu des parties personnelles
c'est-à-dire ou créer autour d'une
personnalité un leader qui d'un seul
coup se lève en disant ben moi j'ai un
message particulier et qui fait sa route
en dehors des appareils partisans
classiques donc où le parti son leader
c'est une seule et même chose quasiment
donc c'est très difficile parce que
décliner ça au niveau local ça voudrait
dire aussi incarner ce macronisme et son
message de départ dans des personnalités
locales mais ces personnalités très
souvent sont nues de familles politiques
déjà constituée et donc on voit toute la
difficulté d'exercices effectivement
vous avez raison ça prend beaucoup de
temps parce qu'il faut trouver des
militants sur le terrain il faut
structurer des réseaux il faut avoir été
élu déjà dans certaines circonscriptions
avant d'y prendre racine donc ça prend
beaucoup de temps on voit que le parti
présidentiel n'a été créé qu'il n'y a
que 7 ans on font même pas 7 ans
fondamentaliste Sophie Coignières tout
le monde se prépare déjà à l'après
Macron avec la question le macronisme
survivra-t-il à Emmanuel Macron avec
donc les les familles politiques qui
pourraient se reconstituer c'est aussi
ça ce qui va se qui va se dessiner
devant nos yeux dans les prochains mois
c'est donc une sorte de vibratoire qui
va falloir regarder très près d'autant
que évidemment il y a une moindre
polarisation ça on l'a vu depuis
les dernières législatives il y a enfin
il y a vraiment une différence bien plus
grande qu'avant entre l'atmosphère si
j'ose dire au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale donc c'est recomposition
peuvent se faire de manière plus feutrée
au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale ça peut
être de ce point de vue un labo vraiment
intéressant alors on va zoomer
maintenant sur les relations entre
Emmanuel Macron et le Sénat Tam moi
quand plusieurs c'est que ça peut être à
long fleuve tranquille on est passé d'un
climat de tension extrême à quoi une
sorte de partenariat plus plus
constructive c'est ça on est passé à
l'entente cordiale rassurez-vous que je
me suis pas trompé
c'est un qualificatif qui correspond
assez bien à ce qui se passe entre
l'exécutif et le Sénat
ça veut dire que entre le Sénat et le
gouvernement il y a eu un traité de paix
il a été signé au mois de juin 2022
c'est celui qui a mis fin à la fameuse
guerre de cinq ans 2017-2022 Emmanuel
Macron était alors à un monarque absolu
en son royaume de l'Assemblée nationale
et il ne parlait pas du tout du tout le
même langage pas la même langue que le
Sénat et donc les relations sont
glaciales l'exemple c'est les ministres
qui boudent et bien les questions au
Gouvernement de la chambre haute il faut
dire qu'ils sont timidement applaudis
par un petit groupuscule de 25 sénateurs
alors qu'ils sont largement ovationnés
par plus de la moitié de l'hémistique à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis au bout
d'un an été 2018 et bien c'est carrément
la guerre ouverte l'affaire Benalla la
commission d'enquête sénatale qui braque
tous les projecteurs sur le travail des
sénateurs des sénateurs que le
gouvernement accuse alors d'être dans le
coup politique et à l'époque un an plus
tard en 2019 genre à l'archet sort
d'ailleurs un livre intitulé
contre-pouvoir qui définit le rôle
à l'époque à la chambre qu'il préside
depuis 2008 est-ce qu'on peut dire que
tout ça n'est plus qu'un lointain
souvenir et bien voilà effectivement
juin 2022 élection législative
en macronie la majorité absolue n'est
plus qu'un lointain souvenir et donc le
gouvernement se met à chercher des
alliés texte par textes enfin surtout à
droite et surtout au Sénat le Sénat
satello de tranquillité de modération
par rapport au bruit à la fureur de
l'Assemblée nationale les présidents de
groupe sont donc souvent reçus par
Elisabeth borne les LR se font draguer
au téléphone par des ministres ils l'ont
raconté et puis les cela devient le
nouveau partenaire du gouvernement
confère le pas de deux qui a été dansé
pendant la réforme des retraites mais la
mission de contrôle dont on parlait ça
continue et oui ça continue malgré tout
parce que c'est une mission qui a permis
au Sénat de retrouver tout de même ses
lettres de noblesse un rappel que la
Haute Assemblée a eu essuyer pendant
quelques années ce qu'on appelle en bon
français le Sénat bashing et qu'il a
gagné en popularité en exerçant et là je
cite Benjamin Morel constitutionnaliste
un rôle de contrôle à l'anglo-saxonne
après la commission d'enquêtes Benalla
il y a eu celle sur les cabinets de
conseil celles sur le Stade de France et
puis bien sûr l'année dernière celle sur
le fond Marianne sans que le
gouvernement trouvaille redire Marlène
Schiappa elle-même avait salué le
travail du Sénat avant d'être emporté
par le remaniement il remaniement du
Sénat puisque les élections c'est
dimanche est-ce qu'il peut changer cette
situation on a commencé à en parler on a
commencé à parler du fait que dans cette
majorité de la droite et du centre et
bien il y a Fifty Shades of blue il y a
genre Larcher plus Macron compatible un
certain loyer même à Matignon l'avenir
le dira que Bruno Retailleau qui est
président lui du groupe LR et qui défend
une ligne très droitière et opposée au
gouvernement et puis vous avez bien sûr
Hervé Marseille le président de l'UDI le
président du groupe Union centriste au
Sénat qui règne sur un groupe baroque
vous avez aussi bien des alliés de la
macronie que de faire vos opposants on a
donc on attend donc devoir où se
rangeront les prochains élus dimanche et
surtout vous l'avez dit le juge de paix
c'est bien sûr le projet de loi
immigration on sait déjà que ça frotte
un peu entre LR et centriste et c'est
alors seulement qu'on verra si le Sénat
peut être un partenaire peut être un
appui ou un colocataire pour
gouvernement en recherche de majorité
merci beaucoup Tam je vais citer du
thème traduit c'est ça fait classe quand
même
un partenaire un appui ou un colocataire
Sophie Cognard vous qu'est-ce que vous
votez pour laquelle de ces hypothèses
en tout cas c'est une enfin je trouve
que c'est une excellente définition de
des hypothèses des hypothèses possibles
moi je trouve que c'est enfin
Joker je ne peux pas dire impossible
d'anticiper sur ce que sera la stratégie
de la nouvelle majorité sénatoriale qui
sera sans doute de la même couleur que
la précédente c'est très compliqué parce
que plus encore enfin comment vous dire
jusqu'ici
le groupe LR n'a pas été vraiment mis
n'a pas vraiment eu l'épreuve du feu qui
va arriver encore une fois avec la loi
de migration donc est-ce qu'il va rester
unis et ferme derrière son président
Bruno Retailleau qui comme vous l'avez
dit
afficher clairement les lignes rouges
comme on dit sur la loi immigration donc
est-ce que comme un seul homme tous les
sénateurs du groupe LR
voilà certains pour lâcher les centres
j'ai les centrist
là enfin je veux dire dans ces cas-là
est-ce qu'effectivement les centrices
vont rester sur cette loi des alliés
j'allais dire docile c'est pas très
sympa mais ça a toujours été un peu le
cas
de la droite pas sûr Sophie Je vous
libère parce que j'avais pris la le
l'engagement
et vous avez un train et donc merci
beaucoup c'était toujours aussi
passionnant de vous avoir sur ce plateau
vouliez intervenir à Charlène sur ce
thème sur cette stratégie qu'elle sera
forcément unitaire est-ce qu'il y aura
une stratégie du Sénat on parle
plusieurs fois de variables d'ajustement
je crois qu'on a vraiment raison
pourquoi ne pas profiter justement
complètement de ce rôle de variable
d'ajustement pour le groupe centriste
pas seulement c'est-à-dire se dire texte
par texte moment politique par moment
politique et bien le Sénat pourra
choisir d'être un peu plus dans
l'opposition un peu plus dans la
critique et je crois vraiment que les
sénateurs ont un sens politique du
pragmatisme qui leur permettra vraiment
de ne pas se brûler les ailes pour
l'avenir il y a le budget qui arriveront
bientôt sur lesquels le Sénat l'habitude
de travailler très en profondeur un
petit mot aussi des alliances n'oublions
pas qu'on a aujourd'hui une Assemblée
nationale qui est faite presque
exclusivement de coalition la coalition
majoritaire la coalition Nupe sauf le
rassemblement national qui a un groupe
identitaire marqué le Sénat n'est pas
familier du tout de ce type de coalition
et chacun des groupes a vraiment une
identité même le groupe radical RDSE qui
est un peu obscur sous la Cinquième
République mais qui a son identité et
donc le Sénat ne peut pas jouer le même
rôle politique où égard notamment à
cette question des coalitions le Sénat
qui bénéficie d'un effet miroir quand on
compare ces débats à ceux de l'Assemblée
nationale le travail transpartisant il
est possible je propose d'écouter la
sénatrice centriste du Nord Valérie le
tard elle aussi ne se représente pas une
pointe de nostalgie dans ce qu'elle nous
dit
cette maison elle est formidable
où sait-on en même temps défendre des
idées chevillées au corps
on se Rossignol il y a assassis Bruno
retaillod enfin
surtout les bancs on a des gens
empreintes conviction et de valeur mais
quand il s'agit de défendre des sujets
d'intérêt
d'intérêt généraux d'intérêt nationaux
on sait travailler les violences
conjugales le zan on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure
transpartisan des textes votés du Parti
communiste Cécile dukarmain qui qui a
défendu le texte enfin quand on est sur
des sujets qui sont essentiels pour nos
collectivités nos territoires ou nos
populations on sait passer ces barrières
on sait travailler dans l'intérêt
général on sait travailler main dans la
main on sait être au combat quand il le
faut et il y a un respect mutuel je
rappelle le zan zéro artificialisation
net objectif 2050 mais c'est pas le
thème de notre débat la bonne au
contraire ce travail transpartisan là
mis en avant par par la sénatrice il est
quand même assez peu connu des Français
alors nous on fait notre job et
heureusement que nous on le fait parce
que sinon personne le fera notre place
mais ça reste un peu sous les radars oui
ça reste sur le radars sous les radars
parce que la tension médiatique dans
l'espace public elle est captée par la
confrontation sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale majorité
opposition tout le monde sait quand même
plus ou moins que nos institutions
fonctionnent sur le mode que à la fin
l'Assemblée nationale peut avoir le
dernier mot mais c'est vrai que ce
travail de à la fois de dialogue de
co-construction basse très largement
sous les radars on pourra en dire la
même chose du conseil économique social
environnemental qui fait aussi un énorme
travail de représentation de la société
civile et lorsqu'on discute avec des
membres de cette Assemblée disent mais
nous on arrive à discuter le patronal
est syndicat arrive à discuter mais
est-ce que c'est vraiment une demande
des Français parce que c'est une
question qu'on pose depuis 18 mois
depuis le résultat de la des élections
législatives en fait on s'est dit après
législatives au finalement on se vote
des Français c'est un message envoyé à
la classe politique
ensemble créer des coalitions faites des
majorités on va dire texte par textes ou
alors peut-être une coalition est-ce que
les Français veulent vraiment ça d'après
il y a une dualité de l'aspiration des
Français en l'a testé nous dans nos
enquêtes qu'on réalise aussi on a
demandé qu'est-ce qu'ils vont est-ce
qu'il faudrait que les personnalités
politiques dialogues entre elles
qu'elles prennent de temps aussi de
consulter les citoyens ou alors au
contraire est-ce qu'il faut des projets
qui clivent et au fond qu'ils aillent
vite qu'ils soient efficaces on veut les
deux on veut les deux ça on veut à la
fois de la confrontation parce que la
confrontation est un vecteur enfin
quelque chose qui permet aux électrices
aux électeurs de s'identifier
d'identifier qui et qui qui défend
quelle position ça permet de voir
clairement le tableau qui est pour qui
est contre la confrontation est
nécessaire en politique mais aussi il
faut pas que la confrontation devienne
une impasse et au fond ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'est ça beaucoup
d'électricité d'électeurs disent on est
dans une situation d'impasse à la fois